bine ai revenit la „Înțelegerea informației și computației cuantice", numele meu este John Matus și sunt directorul tehnic pentru educație la IBM
Quantum. Aceasta este lecția 12 din serie și este ultima lecție din a treia unitate, care tratează formularea generală
a informației cuantice. Această lecție se concentrează pe o noțiune fundamentală în informația cuantică, și anume cea a
purificării unei stări cuantice. O purificare a unei stări cuantice reprezentată de o anumită matrice de densitate este o
stare pură a unui sistem compus mai mare, care ne lasă cu starea originală atunci când restul sistemului compus este
eliminat sau urmat. Orice matrice de densitate are o purificare și putem învăța multe
despre stările cuantice și despre informația cuantică în general studiind purificările. La nivel intuitiv,
vectorii stărilor cuantice, care reprezintă stări pure, sunt obiecte matematice mai simple decât matricele de densitate, iar gândindu-ne la
purificările stărilor, putem privi stările cuantice arbitrare ale sistemelor ca fiind doar părți ale unui ceva mai mare, dar
mai simplu. Vom vorbi și despre fidelitatea dintre două stări cuantice, care este o valoare ce cuantifică
similaritatea sau suprapunerea lor și este adesea folosită ca modalitate de a măsura cât de bună este o anumită stare în comparație cu
o stare ideală. În special, vom discuta definiția fidelității împreună cu unele proprietăți de bază ale acesteia și vom vedea
cum fidelitatea se leagă de purificări. Iată o prezentare generală a lecției: vom începe cu purificările, incluzând
definiția și o demonstrație simplă a existenței lor, care ne arată cum să găsim una dacă avem nevoie. Apoi vom discuta ceva cunoscut
drept descompunerea Schmidt a unui vector de stare cuantică pentru două sisteme și vom vedea cum descompunerile Schmidt se raportează la
purificări. Apoi vom discuta o relație de importanță crucială între oricare două purificări ale aceleiași stări, care este cunoscută drept
echivalența unitară a purificărilor și, în final, vom trece prin câteva exemple. Trecem apoi la fidelitate,
incluzând definiția și unele proprietăți de bază. Vom vorbi despre lema măsurătorii blânde, care este un fapt foarte
util ce leagă fidelitatea de măsurători și, în final, pentru a încheia lecția, vom trece la teorema lui Uhlmann, care
stabilește o conexiune fundamentală între fidelitate și purificări. Să începem cu
definiția purificării. O purificare a unei stări pe care o presupunem reprezentată de o matrice de densitate
este o stare pură a unui sistem compus mai mare, care lasă starea originală cu care am început atunci când restul
sistemului compus este urmat. Putem exprima aceasta mai precis în termeni matematici după cum
urmează: dacă avem un sistem X care se află într-o stare ρ, adică ρ este o matrice de densitate reprezentând o stare a lui X,
și S este un vector de stare cuantică al unei perechi de sisteme XY, astfel încât urmărind y din starea pură obținem
ρ, atunci spunem că S este o purificare a lui ρ. Firesc, numele nu contează —
ne putem numi sistemele și stările cum dorim, iar ordinea sistemelor nu contează nici ea. De exemplu,
dacă sistemul y ar fi pe stânga în loc de pe dreapta, dar totul altfel era la fel, tot am numi S o purificare a lui ρ. Dar
vom rămâne în principal la această configurație pentru restul lecției, doar de dragul simplității. Primul lucru de spus
despre definiție este că purificările există întotdeauna pentru orice matrice de densitate ρ; mai precis, orice matrice de densitate
ρ are o purificare ca cea descrisă în definiție, cu condiția ca sistemul y să fie cel puțin la fel de mare ca X, adică
y să aibă cel puțin tot atâtea stări clasice câte are X. Noțiunea de purificare și
faptul că purificările există întotdeauna se dovedește a fi de importanță critică și face parte din ceea ce face informația cuantică frumoasă; sper că voi
reuși să te conving de acest fapt până la sfârșitul lecției. Acum să demonstrăm că orice matrice de densitate are o purificare și, în
procesul ăsta, vom vedea cum putem obține o purificare atunci când avem nevoie de una. La fel ca în definiție,
să presupunem că X este un sistem și ρ este o matrice de densitate care reprezintă o stare a
lui X. Acum consideră orice expresie a lui ρ ca o combinație convexă de stări pure, așa cum am scris pe ecran. Cu alte cuvinte,
pentru o alegere oarecare a unui număr întreg pozitiv n, avem un vector de probabilitate p₀, ..., p_, precum și vectori de stare cuantică
φ₀, ..., φ_, și luând media stărilor pure corespunzătoare ponderate de probabilități
obținem ρ. De exemplu, am putea folosi teorema spectrală pentru a obține o expresie a lui ρ de acest tip; dacă am face asta,
am putea lua n egal cu numărul de stări clasice ale lui X. De fapt, am putea lua n egal cu rangul lui ρ, care este
egal cu numărul de valori proprii nenule ale lui ρ, numărând fiecare cu multiplicitate, și
acesta nu este niciodată mai mare decât numărul de stări clasice ale lui X, dar ar putea fi mai mic. Pe de altă parte, aceasta nu
trebuie să fie o descompunere spectrală a lui ρ și nu avem nevoie ca acești vectori de stare cuantică să fie ortogonali. De exemplu, orice expresie a lui ρ de acest tip
este în regulă. Și iată o purificare a lui ρ: suma se desfășoară pe aceleași valori ca
în expresia noastră pentru ρ, iar în interiorul sumei luăm rădăcinile pătrate ale probabilităților înmulțite cu φₐ tensorizat
cu |a⟩. Aici, prin convenție, presupunem că 0, ..., n-1 sunt stări clasice ale celui de-al doilea sistem y, deci
are sens că S este un vector de stare cuantică al perechii XY, ca în definiție. Nu este de fapt important
că folosim stări ale bazei standard a lui Y în această expresie — poți substitui orice colecție ortonormată de
stări în locul |0⟩, ..., |n-1⟩ dacă vrei. Acum putem verifica că aceasta este într-adevăr
o purificare calculând urma parțială față de y. Iată o expresie a stării obținute prin calculul urmei parțiale:
urma lui |a⟩⟨b| este fie 1, fie 0, în funcție de dacă a este sau nu egal cu b, deci expresia
se simplifică la expresia originală a lui ρ. E simplu de tot, deci este foarte ușor să obținem o
purificare atât timp cât avem suficiente stări clasice ale lui Y sau, alternativ, un set ortonormat suficient de mare de utilizat în
locul stărilor bazei standard |0⟩, ..., |n-1⟩. Apropo, dacă numărul
de stări clasice ale lui Y este mai mic decât rangul lui ρ, atunci nu va exista o purificare, și las asta
să îl gândești tu, dacă alegi să o faci. Iată un exemplu: să considerăm
matricea de densitate pe care am văzut-o de mai multe ori în lecția despre matrice de densitate. Avem aici o expresie a acestei
matrice de densitate ca o combinație convexă de stări pure — nu este o descompunere spectrală, dar nu
ne pasă — și fără aproape niciun efort putem scrie o purificare a stării urmând
rețeta. Aceasta nu este singura purificare a acestei matrice de densitate — purificările nu sunt unice, dar e în regulă.
WEBVTT
Definiția nu spune nimic despre unicitate și, de fapt, există o relație foarte interesantă între diferitele purificări ale aceleiași stări, dar
vom discuta asta puțin mai târziu în lecție. Urmează descompunerile Schmidt, care sunt expresii ale
vectorilor de stare cuantică bipartite într-o anumită formă pe care o voi descrie imediat. Poartă numele lui Erhard
Schmidt, același Schmidt cunoscut pentru procedura de ortonormare Gram-Schmidt, dar în cazul descompunerilor Schmidt probabil că nu ar fi trebuit
să poarte numele lui Schmidt — e matematic echivalent cu ceva numit descompunerea valorilor singulare pentru matrice, care a fost
redescoperită de mai multe ori, dar asta se mai întâmplă. Oricum, iată ce înțelegem
prin descompunere Schmidt: pentru o alegere arbitrară a unui vector de stare cuantică S pentru o pereche de
sisteme XY, este întotdeauna posibil să scrii S într-o formă specială, și anume cea pe care o
avem pe ecran, unde R este un număr întreg pozitiv, p₀, ..., p_ sunt numere reale pozitive care
formează împreună un vector de probabilitate, x₀, ..., x_ sunt vectori unitari corespunzători sistemului X, și y₀,
..., y_ sunt vectori unitari corespunzători sistemului y. S-ar putea să nu pară deosebit de
special până când îți spun că ambele mulțimi x₀, ..., x_ și y₀, ..., y_ trebuie să fie
ortonormate. Deci de ce e special? Ei bine, dacă am alege orice bază pentru una dintre cele două baze, să zicem
vectorii X corespunzători sistemului X, atunci am putea exprima întotdeauna S în această formă, ceea ce ne-ar forța să
alegem vectorii Y într-un mod specific. De fapt, facem asta destul de des, ca atunci când folosim baza standard pentru
a analiza o măsurătoare în baza standard. Dar în general, chiar dacă alegem o bază ortonormată pentru vectorii X,
vectorii Y pe care îi obținem nu vor fi neapărat ortonormați. Similar, dacă ai alege o
bază ortonormată pentru vectorii Y și ai încerca să exprimi S în această formă, ai putea, dar vectorii X nu ar fi
neapărat ortonormați. Și în final, dacă ai alege vectori ortonormați pentru ambele sisteme și
ai încerca să exprimi S într-o formă ca aceasta, nu ar funcționa neapărat pentru că ai putea avea nevoie de niște termeni încrucișați, dar există doar un singur
indice în această sumă, care este a, deci forma este specială. Dar este întotdeauna posibil să
scrii un vector unitar dat S în acest fel, și iată cum poți face asta: calculează mai întâi o descompunere spectrală
pentru starea redusă a unuia dintre cele două sisteme — nu contează care, dar pentru a descrie cum se face, să ne uităm la starea redusă a
lui X, deci urmărim y. Asta înseamnă că p₀, ..., p_ sunt valorile proprii
ale stării reduse ρ, iar x₀, ..., x_ sunt vectori proprii unitari corespunzători acestor valori proprii. Prin
convenție, ignorăm termenii pentru care valorile proprii sunt zero, deoarece acei termeni nu contribuie cu nimic la
sumă; adică p₀, ..., p_ sunt toate numere reale pozitive, iar R este numărul de valori proprii nenule
numărând multiplicitățile, care este egal cu rangul lui ρ. Astfel obținem p₀, ..., p_
și x₀, ..., x_, și tot ce rămâne este să găsim vectorii y₀, ..., y_.
Există o singură alegere care poate funcționa — acei vectori sunt unic determinați în acest moment și pot fi
găsiți cu ușurință folosind formula simplă prezentată pe ecran. Ce e uimitor este că
dacă definim acești vectori în acest mod, atunci se garantează că sunt ortonormați, ceea ce ne dă o descompunere Schmidt. Nu voi demonstra asta în acest
videoclip, dar nu este prea dificil și poți consulta materialul scris pentru lecție dacă ești interesat — verifică
descrierea videoclipului pentru un link, ca de obicei. Ca exemplu, să considerăm acest
vector de stare cuantică pe care l-am obținut ca purificare a exemplului de matrice de densitate la care ne tot întoarcem.
Nu este o descompunere Schmidt deoarece stările zero și plus nu sunt ortonormate, dar putem găsi una
folosind procedura pe care tocmai am descris-o. Primul pas este să calculăm o descompunere spectrală pentru starea redusă
a lui X, care este același exemplu de matrice de densitate, și iată o descompunere spectrală a ei pe care am văzut-o
în lecția 9. Deci alegem p₀, p₁, x₀ și x₁ cum este
arătat pe ecran: p₀ și p₁ sunt valorile proprii ale lui ρ, iar x₀ și x₁ sunt
vectori proprii unitari corespunzători. Rămâne de calculat y₀ și y₁ și, dacă facem asta, obținem |+⟩
pentru y₀ și -1 × |−⟩ pentru y₁. Nu este imediat —
trebuie să faci efectiv calculul pentru a vedea asta — dar asta obținem, și, cum era de așteptat, cei doi vectori sunt ortonormați, ca
întotdeauna dacă ai făcut calculele corect. Asta ne dă o descompunere
Schmidt. Descompunerile Schmidt sunt foarte utile în multe situații și în curând vom vedea ce ne spun
ele despre purificări. Purificările nu sunt unice — o stare cuantică dată reprezentată
de o matrice de densitate va avea de fapt infinit de multe purificări. Există totuși o relație strânsă
care se menține întotdeauna între oricare două purificări ale aceleiași stări, și este uneori numită
echivalența unitară a purificărilor. Iată cum funcționează: fie ρ o matrice de densitate
reprezentând o stare cuantică a unui sistem X și să presupunem că avem oricare două purificări ale acelei stări care sunt
stări pure ale aceluiași sistem compus. Deci, de dragul concretitudinii, să presupunem că S și φ
sunt vectori de stare cuantică ai unei perechi de sisteme XY care ne dau ambii ρ atunci când sistemul Y este urmărit.
Ce spune echivalența unitară a purificărilor este că trebuie să existe o operație unitară U care acționează doar pe
sistemul y și care transformă S în φ. Cu alte cuvinte, deși acestea sunt
purificări arbitrare ale lui ρ și nu presupunem nimic despre ele, în afara faptului că ambele purifică ρ și sunt
ambele stări ale aceluiași sistem compus XY, ele trebuie să fie echivalente într-un anumit sens, la o operație unitară pe y.
Vom vedea câteva exemple care ilustrează de ce este interesant și ce implicații are, dar mai întâi
să vedem de ce este adevărat. Să începem cu o descompunere spectrală a lui ρ, care este
matricea de densitate pe care atât S, cât și φ o purifică. La fel ca atunci când am discutat descompunerea Schmidt,
vom presupune că am aruncat toți termenii corespunzători valorilor proprii zero, deci p₀, ..., p_
sunt toți numere reale pozitive, x₀, ..., x_ sunt vectori proprii ortonormați ai lui ρ, iar R este
WEBVTT
rangul lui ρ. Apropo, ca o paranteză, observă cât de des apelăm la teorema spectrală în acest moment —
este un instrument incredibil de util și, de fapt, ne-am pierde fără el. Oricum, acum că avem o descompunere
spectrală a lui ρ, putem calcula descompunerile Schmidt ale celor doi vectori ai noștri, la fel ca înainte, și vor fi
aproape identice. Coeficienții și vectorii X sunt aceiași pentru că provin din descompunerea spectrală a stării reduse, care
este aceeași pentru ambii vectori. Singura diferență este că putem obține vectori diferiți pentru al doilea sistem: pentru
primul vector, care este S, vom obține un set de vectori y₀, ..., y_, iar pentru al doilea vector, care este φ, vom
obține o colecție posibil diferită pe care o putem numi z₀, ..., z_. Astfel avem descompuneri Schmidt
pentru cei doi vectori care arată foarte similar, cu excepția că vectorii pentru al doilea sistem pot fi diferiți. Dar acestea
sunt descompuneri Schmidt, deci aceste două colecții sunt ambele ortonormate și, astfel, putem pur și simplu alege
o matrice unitară U care trimite yₐ în zₐ pentru fiecare a. Poți face întotdeauna asta — operațiile
unitare sunt de fapt echivalente cu aplicațiile liniare care transformă o bază ortonormată în alta. Și dacă
aceste două mulțimi nu acoperă întregul spațiu corespunzător lui Y, le putem extinde întotdeauna pe ambele la baze ortonormate
folosind, în mod coincident, procedura de ortonormare Gram-Schmidt, și astfel se demonstrează
echivalența unitară a purificărilor. În lecția 4 a seriei am discutat protocolul de codificare supradensă
care permite unui expeditor să transmită doi biți clasici unui receptor prin trimiterea unui qubit, cu costul unui ebit de
entanglement partajat. Presupun deci că ești deja familiarizat cu acel protocol, iar scopul acestui exemplu este să
explice pe scurt cum se leagă de echivalența unitară a purificărilor. Amintește-ți că modul în care
funcționează protocolul este că Alice și Bob împart un ebit, adică o stare Bell |Φ⁺⟩. Alice alege să transforme acea
stare Bell în oricare dintre cele patru stări Bell, în funcție de cei doi biți pe care vrea să îi trimită, și apoi trimite
qubit-ul ei lui Bob, iar el măsoară pentru a vedea ce stare Bell are. Observă că toate cele patru stări Bell
ne dau aceeași stare redusă pentru qubit-ul lui Bob, care este starea complet mixtă, și de fapt asta e deja suficient
pentru a concluziona că codificarea supradensă este posibilă. Toate cele patru stări Bell purifică starea complet mixtă, deci prin
echivalența unitară a purificărilor știm că trebuie să fie posibil ca Alice să transforme starea Bell |Φ⁺⟩ în
oricare dintre celelalte prin aplicarea unei operații unitare pe qubit-ul ei. Desigur, nu e greu să găsești operații unitare care
chiar funcționează și sunt foarte simple, dar este interesant totuși că putem ajunge la concluzia că asta este
posibil fără să ne gândim deloc la operațiile unitare în sine. Mai mult, putem concluziona
că generalizările codificării supradense la sisteme mai mari sunt posibile, cu condiția să avem un mod de a generaliza stările Bell la sisteme mai mari
astfel încât toate să dea starea complet mixtă ca stare redusă a lui Bob, și există de fapt diferite moduri cunoscute de a face
asta. Un alt cadru în care echivalența unitară a purificărilor are implicații este
criptografia cuantică, și una dintre cele mai importante implicații ale sale este că exclude existența unui protocol cuantic necondiționat securizat pentru o
primitivă criptografică cunoscută sub numele de angajamentul față de un bit. Deci ce este angajamentul față de un bit? Angajamentul față de un bit este un exemplu
de primitivă criptografică, prin care înțelegem o sarcină sau procedură de nivel scăzut care oferă o funcționalitate de bază ce
poate fi folosită ca bloc de construcție pentru a face lucruri mai interesante, cum ar fi crearea schemelor de semnătură digitală sau construirea
protocoalelor de cunoaștere zero. De exemplu, în cazul angajamentului față de un bit, funcționalitatea de bază este că un
jucător, Alice, poate să se angajeze față de o valoare binară la alegerea ei față de un al doilea jucător, Bob, dar alegerea ei rămâne ascunsă
până când alege să o dezvăluie. Avem nevoie de două proprietăți specifice de la un protocol care implementează angajamentul față de
un bit: trebuie să fie obligatoriu, ceea ce înseamnă că Alice nu poate să își schimbe hotărârea odată ce s-a angajat față de un bit, și
trebuie să fie ascuns, ceea ce înseamnă că Bob nu poate determina bitul lui Alice până când ea alege să îl dezvăluie.
Ar fi destul de util să putem implementa această primitivă folosind informația cuantică, pentru că este o
primitivă utilă, dar fără ipoteze suplimentare se dovedește a fi imposibil să o faci perfect cu informație cuantică sau chiar aproape
de perfect. Iar echivalența unitară a purificărilor arată că ideea, la un nivel înalt, este
că dacă ar exista un protocol cuantic pentru angajamentul față de un bit, ar trebui să existe o versiune purificată a acelui protocol în care putem imagina că
Alice are un sistem A, Bob are un sistem B, și după ce angajamentul este făcut, dar înainte ca Alice să dezvăluie, perechea AB se află în
una din două stări pure |ψ₀⟩ sau |ψ₁⟩, în funcție de bitul față de care Alice se
angajează. Dacă protocolul este perfect ascuns, atunci trebuie că Bob nu poate face diferența între cele
două angajamente, deci starea lui redusă trebuie să fie aceeași pentru cele două posibilități. Dar asta implică, prin
echivalența unitară a purificărilor, că Alice poate transforma oricare dintre ele în cealaltă aplicând o operație unitară
pe A singur. Deci protocolul a eșuat complet să fie obligatoriu. Există detalii pe care le-am trecut cu vederea, dar
esența este că echivalența unitară a purificărilor ne spune că această primitivă nu este ceva
ce putem implementa de încredere folosind informație cuantică fără ipoteze suplimentare de un anumit
fel. Ultimul exemplu al unei implicații a echivalenței unitare a purificărilor este o teoremă cunoscută drept
teorema Hughston-Jozsa-Wootters, sau teorema HJW pe scurt. Să începem cu enunțul
teoremei, care este o versiune ușor simplificată pentru a evita unele detalii tehnice și a ne concentra pe ideile principale.
Să presupunem că X și Y sunt sisteme și φ este orice vector de stare cuantică reprezentând o stare pură a perechii
XY, și acum să presupunem că ne gândim la starea redusă a sistemului X singur și venim cu orice mod în care
alegem să exprimăm această stare redusă ca o combinație convexă de stări pure, așa cum este arătat pe ecran.
De exemplu, numărul N mare în această expresie, care este numărul de stări pure peste care facem media, ar putea
fi arbitrar de mare, posibil mult mai mare decât dimensiunea spațiului corespunzător lui X sau Y.
Și ce ne spune teorema este că trebuie să existe o măsurătoare pe sistemul y cu N rezultate astfel încât
să se întâmple următoarele: când sistemul Y este măsurat, în primul rând, fiecare rezultat al măsurătorii
apare cu probabilitate exact egală cu probabilitatea corespunzătoare din expresia noastră a stării reduse a lui X ca
WEBVTT
o combinație convexă de stări pure, și în al doilea rând, condiționat de obținerea unui anumit rezultat al măsurătorii,
starea lui X devine starea pură corespunzătoare din combinația convexă. Deci de ce este asta
interesant? Ei bine, înseamnă că pentru orice mod în care alegem să ne gândim la starea redusă a lui X ca o combinație convexă
de stări pure, există o măsurătoare a lui Y care face efectiv ca această modalitate de a gândi despre starea redusă a lui X să devină
o realitate. Ce este remarcabil este că asta este posibil chiar și atunci când starea φ este aleasă mai întâi și combinația convexă
este aleasă mai târziu — atât timp cât este o expresie a stării reduse a lui X, va exista o
măsurătoare a lui Y care funcționează exact astfel. Deci să vedem cum putem demonstra
asta. Pornim cu două expresii diferite pentru starea redusă a lui X, căreia îi vom da numele ρ pentru
comoditate. Urmează să introducem un nou sistem Z ale cărui stări clasice sunt posibilele rezultate ale măsurătorii sau,
echivalent, indicii din combinația noastră convexă. Acum putem observa că următori doi vectori de stare cuantică
γ₀ și γ₁, care sunt ambii vectori de stare pentru sistemul compus XYZ, sunt
ambii purificări ale lui ρ. Și, ca să fie clar, atunci când ne gândim la acești vectori ca purificări ale lui ρ, ne gândim
la sistemele Y și Z împreună ca un singur sistem compus care este urmat pentru a lăsa
ρ. Primul vector γ₀ este practic același lucru ca starea pură originală φ, cu excepția că inițializăm
noul sistem Z la starea zero. Este clar că dacă urmărim Y și Z vom rămâne cu ρ, deci γ₀
este o purificare a lui ρ. Al doilea vector γ₁ este practic vectorul obținut prin purificarea
lui ρ pe baza combinației convexe, la fel cum am descris mai devreme în lecție. De data aceasta sistemul Y este
inițializat — presupun doar de dragul simplității că zero este o stare clasică a lui Y, dar ai putea substitui orice
stare a bazei standard sau, de fapt, orice stare pură a lui Y în această expresie fără nicio diferență. În orice caz, urmărind Y și
Z din nou obținem ρ, deci concluzia este că acestea sunt ambele purificări ale lui ρ și, prin urmare, prin
echivalența unitară a purificărilor, există o operație unitară U pe perechea YZ care transformă γ₀ în
γ₁. Și asta e tot ce avem nevoie pentru a veni cu o descriere a unei măsurători care face ce spune teorema.
O modalitate simplă de a o descrie este cu o diagramă de circuit ca cea arătată pe ecran. Cu alte cuvinte, pornim cu
starea φ, introducem Z inițializat la starea zero, efectuăm U și apoi măsurăm sistemul de sus, care este Z, cu o
măsurătoare în baza standard. În esență, asta transformă φ în γ₁ și
doar privind descrierea lui γ₁ putem vedea că asta face ce spune teorema, adică obținem
fiecare rezultat a cu probabilitate pₐ și condiționat de obținerea lui a, sistemul X rămâne în starea |ψₐ⟩.
Și, ca să fie clar, măsurătoarea în sine a cărei existență o implică teorema este implementată de
tot ce se află în dreptunghiul punctat din figură. Și dacă vrei să știi cum poate fi
descrisă măsurătoarea ca o colecție de matrice, iată o expresie a lor. Nu voi explica această parte și nu este
cu adevărat importantă pentru exemplu, dar aceea este o expresie a matricelor de măsurătoare în caz că ești
interesat. Urmează să discutăm fidelitatea, care este o măsură a cât de similare sunt două stări cuantice, sau alternativ, cât de mult
se suprapun. Vom începe cu definiția, care ar putea părea un pic misterioasă la
prima vedere, dar o vom desface și sper că la sfârșitul discuției te voi fi convins că este
de fapt o funcție mult mai drăguță decât ar părea la prima vedere. Și iată
definiția: fidelitatea dintre două matrice de densitate ρ și σ este egală cu urma radicalului pătrat al
radicalului pătrat al lui ρ înmulțit cu σ înmulțit cu radicalul pătrat al lui ρ. Să vorbim despre
asta — mai întâi, să încercăm să înțelegem definiția în sine. Avem trei radicali pătrate și
toți se referă la radicalul pătrat al unei matrice semipozitiv definite, care, cum am discutat în lecția anterioară, este
unica matrice semipozitiv definită al cărei pătrat ne dă matricea al cărei radical îl calculăm. Deoarece
ρ este o matrice de densitate, trebuie să fie semipozitiv definită, deci putem lua radicalul ei, și dacă ne gândim la radicalul lui ρ
înmulțit cu σ înmulțit cu radicalul lui ρ pentru o clipă, vedem că este și el semipozitiv definit și, în particular, îl putem scrie ca
M† × M, unde M este radicalul pătrat al lui σ înmulțit cu radicalul pătrat al lui ρ, și astfel putem lua radicalul
pătrat al lui. În particular, putem calcula o descompunere spectrală a radicalului
lui ρ înmulțit cu σ înmulțit cu radicalul lui ρ, și pentru a lua radicalul pătrat trebuie doar să luăm rădăcinile pătrate ale valorilor
proprii și să lăsăm vectorii proprii neschimbați. Și în final luăm urma
acestei matrice și, deoarece urma este egală cu suma valorilor proprii, obținem expresia pe care o avem chiar
aici. Deci probabil că nu ai vrea să calculezi asta de mână în general, iar această explicație s-ar putea să nu ofere
prea mult discernământ privind fidelitatea sau de ce ne pasă de ea, dar sper că clarifică sensul tehnic
al formulei. Apropo, ca o paranteză, uneori oamenii definesc fidelitatea ca
pătratul funcției pe care am definit-o chiar acum și numesc această funcție fidelitatea
rădăcină. O vei vedea definită în ambele moduri, ceea ce are potențialul de a provoca confuzie, dar de obicei nu o face
deoarece oamenii sunt în general destul de atenți să clarifice ce definiție folosesc, și ar trebui
să faci același lucru. Din perspectiva mea nu există o definiție corectă sau greșită — o definesc
astfel pur și simplu pentru că m-am obișnuit să o fac în acest mod și, sincer, o găsesc un pic mai convenabilă — cred că prefer să ridic la pătrat
decât să extrag un radical mai târziu când e nevoie. Dar, desigur, ești liber să faci propria
alegere. Oricum, să revin la fidelitate, așa cum este definită aici. Există și alte moduri echivalente de a
defini fidelitatea și este o funcție destul de remarcabilă în această privință — poate fi caracterizată în câteva moduri destul de interesante.
Iată o modalitate destul de directă de a rescrie definiția în termeni de norma urmă, pe care am văzut-o spre
sfârșitul lecției anterioare. Nu am intrat în prea multe detalii despre norma urmă și, în particular,
nici nu am definit-o pentru matrice non-hermitiene, dar ea are o definiție suficient de simplă. Un mod de a defini norma urmă a unei
WEBVTT
matrice arbitrare M este că este urma radicalului pătrat al lui M × M† sau, echivalent, urma radicalului
pătrat al lui M† × M — obții aceeași valoare în oricare mod o faci. Putem folosi acea definiție pentru a simplifica
definiția fidelității, cum avem în josul ecranului, și asta e util pentru că arată că
este simetrică în cele două argumente. Putem exprima de asemenea norma urmă a unei matrice pătrate M ca
maximul valorii absolute a urmei lui M × U, luând maximul peste toate matricele unitare U — ceea ce nu este evident, dar este
adevărat — și asta ne dă o altă expresie pentru fidelitate. Deci avem trei
definiții echivalente pentru fidelitate, și asta e doar începutul — există câteva alte definiții echivalente și
vom vedea una deosebit de importantă care provine din teorema lui Uhlmann spre sfârșitul lecției.
OK, asta e bine, dar ce înseamnă la nivel intuitiv și de ce ar trebui să ne pese de această
funcție? Pentru a răspunde la aceste întrebări, e util să considerăm cazul special în care cel puțin una dintre cele două matrice de densitate
reprezintă o stare pură. Dacă ambele stări sunt pure, atunci
fidelitatea este pur și simplu valoarea absolută a produsului intern dintre cei doi vectori de stare cuantică, și în unele privințe
aceasta este o motivație principală pentru fidelitate în sine. Valoarea absolută a produsului intern dintre doi vectori de stare cuantică
este întotdeauna un număr între zero și unu și ne oferă o modalitate naturală de a măsura cât de mult se suprapun
doi vectori de stare cuantică. Poți să te gândești la fidelitate ca la o modalitate utilă și bine comportată de a
extinde această măsurare a suprapunerii de la stări pure la matrice de densitate. Dacă una dintre stări este pură
și cealaltă nu este neapărat pură, atunci avem din nou o expresie simplă pentru fidelitate care poate fi destul de
utilă, și acea expresie este arătată chiar aici. Fidelitatea are multe proprietăți interesante,
și acesta este unul dintre motivele pentru care oamenii o folosesc. Are o definiție care nu este cu adevărat
prea drăguță, dar este o funcție foarte utilă totuși, și adesea este foarte ușor de folosit, în parte datorită multor sale
proprietăți remarcabile. Deci hai să aruncăm o privire la unele dintre ele, începând cu observația că fidelitatea dintre două matrice de densitate
este întotdeauna un număr între 0 și 1. Este zero dacă și numai dacă stările
sunt ortogonale, adică imaginile sunt subspații ortogonale, sau echivalent, produsul celor două matrice este
zero. Iar fidelitatea este 1 dacă și numai dacă cele două matrice de densitate sunt egale. Orice alt caz este undeva
între, dar în mod intuitiv, cu cât fidelitatea este mai aproape de 1, cu atât stările sunt mai similare sau, alternativ,
cu atât se suprapun mai mult. Fidelitatea este de asemenea simetrică — am menționat asta cu câteva momente în urmă —
este destul de clar din expresia pe care am văzut-o pentru fidelitate în termeni de norma urmă, dar este un lucru important de recunoscut
totuși. Urmează: fidelitatea este multiplicativă pentru stări produs, ceea ce înseamnă că fidelitatea dintre două
stări produs este întotdeauna egală cu produsul fidelităților dintre stările individuale.
Iată o proprietate cu adevărat utilă: dacă avem orice două matrice de densitate de aceeași dimensiune
împreună cu orice canal care ia aceste matrice de densitate ca intrare, fidelitatea poate doar să crească atunci când acel canal
este aplicat ambelor stări. Deci, cu alte cuvinte, în termeni de fidelitate, canalele pot doar face stările
mai similare una cu cealaltă — nu le pot face mai puțin similare. Și în final, pentru această listă oricum,
există o relație destul de strânsă între fidelitate și distanța urmă dintre stări, care este definită
ca jumătate din norma urmă a diferenței dintre cele două matrice de densitate. Distanța urmă dintre două
stări se leagă puternic de cât de bine le putem distinge, lucru pe care l-am discutat în lecția anterioară în contextul
discriminării stărilor și a teoremei Helstrom-Holevo. În timp ce fidelitatea cuantifică cât de mult se suprapun două stări,
deci deși nu sunt exact același lucru, nu este surprinzător că există o relație între aceste
două cantități. În orice caz, aceste inegalități, numite în mod obișnuit inegalitățile Fuchs–van de Graaf, fac
această relație precisă din punct de vedere matematic, și este destul de important că nu există nicio dependență de dimensiunea sistemului despre care vorbim.
Putem vedea această relație mai clar cu ajutorul unei figuri. Dacă avem două stări și
localizăm distanța urmă dintre ele pe axa x și fidelitatea pe axa y, atunci liniile verticale și
orizontale corespunzătoare trebuie să se intersecteze undeva în interiorul acestei regiuni gri. Cea mai interesantă regiune a
graficului, cel puțin din punct de vedere practic, este colțul din stânga sus al regiunii gri. În particular, atunci când
distanța urmă este foarte mică, fidelitatea trebuie să fie foarte aproape de 1, și viceversa.
Aceste inegalități sunt folosite foarte frecvent, și o parte din motivul pentru asta este că adesea ne pasă mai mult de
distanța urmă în cele din urmă, pentru că are o interpretare naturală legată de discriminarea stărilor cuantice,
dar fidelitatea are atât de multe proprietăți remarcabile încât în general este mai ușor de lucrat cu ea, și atât timp cât ne aflăm în colțul din stânga sus al
regiunii gri, unde ne găsim adesea, nu pierdem prea mult convertind înapoi și între fidelitate și distanța urmă. Deci acestea
sunt câteva dintre proprietățile fidelității — mai sunt multe altele, dar e un început bun și sper că lista este
utilă pentru a începe să-ți dezvolți o intuiție despre fidelitate. Iată un exemplu drăguț de cum putem
lega fidelitatea de măsurători nedestructive. Este un fapt foarte util cunoscut drept Lema Măsurătorii Blânde.
Să presupunem că avem un sistem X, o stare a lui X reprezentată de o matrice de densitate ρ și o măsurătoare pe sistemul X
descrisă de o colecție de matrice semipozitiv definite. Să presupunem că unul dintre rezultatele măsurătorii este foarte probabil să
apară dacă am efectua măsurătoarea pe starea ρ. De dragul simplității, să presupunem
că este rezultatul zero care este foarte probabil și, în particular, să presupunem că acel rezultat apare cu
probabilitate mai mare de 1 − ε, pentru o valoare mică ε pe care nu trebuie să o specificăm — ε este doar
un număr real pozitiv mic. Acum am descris măsurătoarea noastră ca și cum ar fi o măsurătoare destructivă,
dar știm din lecția anterioară că am putea implementa această măsurătoare într-un mod nedestructiv, și anume cum
am văzut în discuția noastră despre teorema lui Naimark: fiecare rezultat a apare cu
probabilitate egală cu urma lui Pₐ × ρ, iar condiționat de obținerea acelui rezultat, starea lui X se schimbă.
WEBVTT
În particular, în cazul în care obținem rezultatul probabil zero, starea devine radicalul pătrat al lui P₀ × ρ × radicalul pătrat al lui P₀,
totul normalizat astfel încât să obținem o matrice de densitate. Și ce ne spune lema măsurătorii blânde este că în acest caz,
adică dacă obținem într-adevăr rezultatul probabil al măsurătorii, starea obținută nu se va fi schimbat foarte mult față de
starea originală, și în particular fidelitatea la pătrat va fi în mod necesar mai mare de 1 minus
ε. Și asta e excelent pentru că este complet general — nu am spus nimic despre măsurătoare sau
stare, în afara faptului că unul dintre rezultate este foarte probabil. Deci lema poate fi aplicată în
multe situații diferite în care am dori să verificăm ceva despre o stare cuantică fără a o deranja prea mult. Deci să vedem cum putem demonstra
asta — în mare parte, este o chestiune destul de simplă de a calcula fidelitatea dintre stările pre- și post-măsurătoare.
Putem face asta folosind definiția originală și în mod normal asta ne-ar lăsa cu o formulă complicată, dar
în acest caz suntem norocoși pentru că lucrul din interiorul radicalului exterior este de fapt pătratul unei matrice care
se întâmplă să fie semipozitiv definită, ceea ce face calculul radicalului trivial. Putem folosi acum proprietatea ciclică
a urmei împreună cu liniaritatea urmei pentru a simplifica expresia, cum este arătat pe ecran. Observă, apropo, că acestea sunt
toate egalități, deci nu am aproximat nimic până acum — pur și simplu simplificăm. Dar acum avem nevoie de o
inegalitate pentru că am dori să scăpăm de acel radical din numărător, și putem face asta dacă suntem dispuși să ne mulțumim cu o margine inferioară. Și dacă
ești interesat de detaliile acestei părți, poți obține inegalitatea destul de ușor considerând o descompunere spectrală a lui P₀ —
valorile proprii ale lui P₀ trebuie să fie între 0 și 1, ceea ce este întotdeauna adevărat pentru matricele care descriu
măsurători, și odată ce știm asta, inegalitatea urmează destul de direct din faptul că extragerea radicalului pătrat al
unui număr între 0 și 1 nu poate decât să îl mărească. Un alt mod de a spune asta este că ridicarea la pătrat a unui număr între 0 și
1 nu poate decât să îl micșoreze. Putem acum simplifica un pic mai mult și obținem radicalul pătrat al
urmei lui P₀ × ρ. Ridicând ambele membre la pătrat și
înlocuind marginea noastră pentru probabilitate obținem ce dorim. Deci formula pentru fidelitate
nu este cea mai drăguță sau mai ușor de folosit formulă din lume, dar aici funcționează destul de
bine. Pentru a încheia lecția, vom arunca o privire la teorema lui Uhlmann, care este un fapt fundamental despre fidelitate ce
o leagă de noțiunea de purificare. Ce spune teorema în termeni simpli este că fidelitatea dintre oricare două
stări cuantice este egală cu produsul intern maxim, în valoare absolută, dintre două purificări ale acelor
stări. Cu ceva mai multe detalii: să presupunem că ρ și σ sunt matrice de densitate pentru un sistem X și să presupunem că Y este un
sistem care are cel puțin tot atâtea stări clasice câte X, și prin urmare avem garanția că ambele stări au purificări care sunt
vectori de stare cuantică ai lui XY. Putem exprima atunci implicația teoremei în forma ecuației
arătate pe ecran: fidelitatea dintre ρ și σ este egală cu valoarea absolută maximă a produsului intern
dintre φ și S, luând maximul peste toate φ și S care purifică ρ și σ
respectiv. Deci să curățăm asta și să lucrăm cu enunțul matematic precis de acum înainte. Ce vom face acum este să demonstrăm
teorema, dar mai întâi merită să ne oprim un moment pentru a aprecia că ne oferă o modalitate destul de intuitivă de a ne gândi la
fidelitate. De asemenea, se dovedește a fi destul de utilă în sine, de exemplu pentru a demonstra lucruri și mai interesante despre
fidelitate. Pentru a o demonstra, vom începe cu descompuneri spectrale ale matricelor noastre de densitate —
nicio surpriză acolo. Odată ce avem descompuneri spectrale, este ușor să venim cu
două purificări specifice ale acestor stări, dar iată că vom folosi de fapt un
truc. Observă că în ambele cazuri nu avem un vector al bazei standard ca al doilea factor tensorial, ca mai devreme în
lecție, ci avem același vector ca în primul factor tensorial, dar cu o bară deasupra, adică
conjugatul complex element cu element al acelor vectori. Deci, cu alte cuvinte, luăm practic o a doua
copie a vectorilor proprii, dar luăm conjugatul complex al fiecărui element, și vom vedea de ce facem asta în câteva
momente — nu este deloc evident că ar trebui să facem asta, și de aceea îl numim
truc. În orice caz, acestea sunt purificări ale lui ρ și σ respectiv, și asta este adevărat în virtutea
faptului că vectorii noștri proprii sunt ortonormați și, prin urmare, la fel sunt conjugatele lor complexe element cu element. Acum putem aplica
echivalența unitară a purificărilor, care spune că orice purificare a celor două stări poate fi obținută prin
aplicarea unei operații unitare la sistemul care este urmat. Pentru alegerile specifice de purificări pe care
tocmai le-am făcut, operațiile unitare nu trebuie să fie aceleași pentru cele două purificări,
desigur, deci folosim litera U pentru prima și litera V pentru a doua.
Deci concluzia este că orice purificare a celor două stări poate fi scrisă cum avem pe ecran pentru
o alegere oarecare a operațiilor unitare U și V. Și acum putem lua expresia
din teoremă și simplifica. Dacă înlocuim expresiile noastre pentru φ și S și simplificăm un pic,
obținem expresia arătată pe ecran. Există câțiva pași acolo pe care nu i-am arătat în detaliu,
dar motivul pentru care am ales purificările cum am ales a fost pentru a permite acestui produs intern
să se simplifice exact în acest mod, și în particular am pus conjugatele complexe acolo pentru a putea
răsturna practic produsele interne din al doilea factor tensorial pentru a obține forma specifică
pe care o avem chiar acum. Aproape am terminat — acum putem folosi proprietatea ciclică a urmei împreună
cu descompunerile spectrale cu care am început pentru a obține această expresie, și în acest moment putem
folosi unul dintre modurile alternative de a exprima fidelitatea folosind norma urmă, și am
terminat. Cu siguranță există detalii acolo pe care le-am trecut rapid și este tipul de demonstrație pe care chiar trebuie să o
parcurgi singur pentru a o înțelege pe deplin, dar sper că aceasta îți oferă ideea de bază,
și ca de obicei, poți găsi mai multe detalii în conținutul scris pentru lecție, care este legat în descrierea videoclipului.
Și aceasta este sfârșitul lecției, care a fost despre purificări, fidelitate și conexiunile dintre ele, și este de asemenea
WEBVTT
sfârșitul unității, care a fost despre formularea generală a informației cuantice. Sper că te vei alătura mie pentru
a patra și ultima unitate a seriei, care tratează corectarea erorilor cuantice. Mulțumesc că ai vizionat!